during the day nadezhda works for a
russian state-funded institution
but her free time is now spent
protesting against the state's latest
attempt to preserve
putin's power for another two terms with
opposition demonstrations banned
stickers are the only way to voice her
anger at being told by her employers
exactly where and when to vote
i think it wasn't our management's
initiative they received the orders from
above
and it must have been done to make sure
people don't participate in exit polls
and there are no election observers
to make sure no one could observe the
voting and to make it more difficult to
uncover irregularities
she is up against a vast machine the
kremlin launched a widespread
advertising campaign
appealing to pensioners parents and
patriots
the 200 amendments to the constitution
include promises on pensions
healthcare and the minimum wage as well
as allowing the current president to
seek re-election after his final term
ends in 2024
and guaranteeing immunity to former
presidents
but a yes or no vote on the entire
package is the only option
available andre klichas was part of the
working group brought together by
president putin
to draft the proposed reforms
the lawyers admit that the current
president has already been elected to
the highest state post several times
there is no reset there is just a
special provision in the text of the
constitution that allows the current
president to run for the next
presidential election
this provision largely guarantees that
the state's policy will not be radically
changed
after 2024. but the vote is largely
symbolic the changes have already been
passed by russia's parliament
still critics say putin wants the people
to give his plan the veneer of
legitimacy
putin wants to be supported by people as
a dictator
this is typical situation for any kind
of
dictatorships such a direct
direct line direct connection between
the autocrat
and the people this is simply his
personal
sociological poll there are fears the
nationwide vote could increase the
spread of coronavirus
in a country that is still recording
over 7 000 new infections a day
a ban on public events led to the arrest
of hundreds of protesters
even one person with a placard is
considered a contravention
but the ban does not apply to any events
organized by the kremlin
though the need for urgency on this vote
is unclear
charlie angela al jazeera